let's bring back CBS News senior
national security analyst that's Fran
Townsend in CBS News law enforcement
Alice that's Paul violas who join us at
the table to discuss you know as often
in this case we keep saying it's a very
fluid situation the facts are always
changing it was interesting that the
authorities have pointed out that social
media did not help in this situation in
fact they caused panic by putting out
false reports but what do we know so far
Paul that we know is true and that
people can say this is what happened
this morning and what that says to you
is a law enforcement officer the thing
that what really speaks in what our
viewers need to understand is that it's
a very fluid much of a fluid situation
but this individual 64 years old no
criminal history is in but yeah yet
calculated enough to select the type of
weapons that would be able to shoot at
400 or 400 yards at thirty two floors up
given those winds here that's a planner
that's somebody that's familiar with
firearms the other part that we know is
that you know thank God Las Vegas PD did
an exceptional job of containing this
and mitigating the shooter because his
friend mentioned earlier and there's no
question about it if that not had
happened there'd be a lot more people
right now on the death care well we hear
no criminal history but we did hear that
he's had some minor run-in with right
officials and I like what you said
earlier he said just because he doesn't
have a criminal record
doesn't mean he doesn't have a criminal
past exactly because there have some
interaction with law enforcement right
and what we'll find as the day
progresses and tomorrow what we'll find
is what police actually communicated
with him when they responded to him at
his home and how many different times
again for viewers to understand is just
because there's no record doesn't mean
that there's no history with respect to
interaction with the shooter in this
particular case so it could be that
clearly it could be that neighbors had
called on him it could be that he's
created problems inside the neighborhood
where police officers would go to
respond to to call an incident but it
could very well speak to and it will
speak to his mental health state do you
have to have experience to use this kind
of weaponry yes yeah a layperson could
not just go in and operate this weapon
no and that's a very poignant question
because again it goes back to if you
looked at the at the the monitor will we
showed where Mandalay Bay is
and where the crime scene was where he
was shooting into where the concert was
you're talking about over 400 yards but
you're talking at thirty two floors up
and taken to account the wind shears and
that that he's going to have to take
account for in order to to release that
those you know that many rounds into
that that particular field so the
experience yes no question about that
and the weapon selection really is going
to speak to the state of mind and his
experience with weapons these hotels
especially of this caliber the Mandalay
Bay Fran you were talking about the
detail that goes into security and you
attend a lot of these conferences the
post mortem following up on on this
tragedy and going forward our hotels
going to have reevaluate how they
approach guests coming in especially
maybe on a day to day basis but knowing
that a concert is going to be or some
masks you know the event is going to be
taking place just feet away from its
doors you know it's interesting you
should ask me on it because you know in
when you travel in Africa Europe India
often times in the wake of the Mumbai
attack you'll recall and that in the Taj
Hotel they now do screen visitors when
they come into hotels they screen your
luggage they screen you you go through a
medical tonight and I do that before
Fran no no no that really was an after
in the aftermath of the Mumbai attack
correct yeah and so but the problem here
so yes they may they certainly will look
at the lessons learned and reevaluate
the security plan here's the problem in
particular with the Mandalay Bay as I
mentioned I've stayed there it's also
connected to the Convention Center and
to a shopping mall which means you've
got multiple points of entry and exit it
would be very difficult to control that
which essentially makes it a soft target
right it's very hard now the hotel maid
make reconsider when there's a big event
whether or not they're going to try to
implement some sort of additional
security measures
I'll tell you though you know the Las
Vegas PD the Sheriff's Department and
the chief security officers at each of
the hotels many of them are retired law
enforcement officers themselves practice
scenarios just like this active shooters
the Department of Homeland Security has
implored state law
vocals to practice the active shooter
drills regularly and that does happen in
Las Vegas we're seeing the benefit of
that here you there would have been
greater fatalities and greater injuries
if they had not been so well-prepared
Vegas itself and the strip is just one
giant outdoor mall essentially I mean
with that number of tourists installing
metal detectors one would think would
require a complete reimagining of the
city and and the Strip in particular
can't even imagine will be involved in
that but Paul as you mentioned that
that's just a it's a question you ask is
what do you want what do you need
balance right and the question that
we're gonna hear and the conversation
we're gonna hear is the days and weeks
come on from here as balance what are we
willing to give up if we really wanted
to have a top-tier fortified level of
security and as Fran said it's a really
important point here you know this
particular facility is connected to a
mall so the just the point of access
into that particular hotel are numerous
oh do we really want and here's the
question do we really want to create a
level of security that every time you go
to a hotel like that no matter where you
are you're gonna be wanted and go
through you know metal detectors is that
something we want that's a conversation
we're gonna have to have I don't think
it is I don't think the balance of make
a guest feel welcome and wounding you at
the same time so you know and his friend
mentioned right there we saw a change in
Mumbai but we have a different culture
here in the United States so I think
that's the conversation we have to have
that's right although I would I will
tell you you know they'll look to see if
there's some compromise right when you
when you look at the size of these
weapons the kind of weapon that he used
it had to have committed luggage right
this was not something on his person or
in a hand carried piece you know a
smaller piece and so it may be that they
decide what they want to do as a
compromise is to screen luggage right
you're camping your luggage in through
the mall you've got to bring it into the
hotel and that luggage itself will be
screened because that would have picked
this up when the guy checked in further
complicated by the fact that when you
think of a loner yeah normally it's a
young person normally it is a white male
in many K
but this is a retiree who's living in a
retirement community doesn't fit any
kind of profile that we've ever been
associated with this kind of thing it
does speak to what his agenda is and you
know we talk about profile we don't know
his yet where his profile is going to
come from as forensic information and
the investigation that's going to occur
right now going through the websites
that he visited and the people that he
knew and that's going to create the
profile what motivated this particular
individual that's going to break it down
as to the why that's gonna answer that's
not to say that the the larger scale
profiling doesn't work many times it's
just that this man may have been an
outlier correct yes there's no question
now science is what it is but it's not
perfect and so Paul they're looking and
looking at his motive right the key
there is gonna be this one the wife who
they now say that they've identified and
they've located talking to her and
understanding his state of mind will be
key to figuring out what was the motive
was he an emotionally disturbed person
and how did this all unfold
so Paul they're looking at mental health
or looking at the weapons they're
looking at job history we know he had
this lawsuit that he filed against one
of the hotels in Las Vegas several years
ago what else our law enforcement
occasion they're gonna see what type of
medication he was on if any at all
they're going to look into was he seeing
any particular type of doctor
specifically if he was seeing somebody
with respect to mental health issues
they're gonna dig down deep in that but
the biggest part that you're going to
find right now is going to be two things
one the artificial intelligence that
they will hopefully have have in place
in the city of Las Vegas which is
information that we get from the
closed-circuit television cameras the
software that will forensic we track
where he came from did he meet with
anybody else a variety of different
things that led up to that and so he
talked to him who did he speak with and
then sell records who did he speak to
how long did he speak to them and then
sit down and interview them that's their
next steps right now